the huge scandal in the world of Star
Wars I'm not talking about jar jar's new
propensity for sending late-night nudes
you slip up I'm talking about the fact
that Lord Miller the directors of the
standalone Han Solo film have left the
project we don't have any real
explanation for the accident having
creative differences so that means we
should wildly speculate without any
regard for the truth whatsoever because
this is the internet truth is overrated
and it's impossible to source so
make up a percentage of people on
Facebook go believe it secreted what are
some actions that would get you fired
from a Star Wars movie in 60 seconds and
begin
and will Wellman calling the Droid our
two DS not yes fine good you get fired
from Star Wars movie if you made three
underwhelming prequels with too much CGI
alright boys
Emma hot shaming yeah my god welcome
Dolph Neil Harrison Ford's earring for
his own good yeah Jordan you replaced
the Cantina song with Carlos Santana's
smooth I need someone to make that
immediately don't be hating Kristensen
yeah boy Emma calling Yoda busted Kermit
yeah
[Applause]
this pig I will
[Laughter]